so the other day I get a call from one
of my friends who's a die-hard Saints
fan diehard NFL fan he says Pat did you
see how this kid this kid named Marcus
Williams missed this tackle and he calls
Drew Brees his second Super Bowl I'm
telling you he would beaten Brady I just
I'm so frustrated whew as this guy
should be fired as you get rid of this
should cut him he doesn't belong in the
NFL I could have made this tackle and
he's just going off on this kid he's
never met and by the way this kid named
Marcus Williams he's living his dreams
he's playing in the NFL on the biggest
platform millions of people watching
this guy and he made one mistake where
the world knows about the entire mistake
he made listen there are three types of
people in the world there are fans there
are critics and there are doors that
play in the arena and by the way you
know what's the most dangerous position
to me and the ones that playing in the
arena you know why here's why I want you
to think about if you're this kid named
Marcus Williams after the game Steven
Naismith you know he's gonna talk smack
about you ESPN newspaper magazines
Sports Illustrated the biggest mistake
of all time the biggest dumbest mistakes
on every list you can make as a mistake
he's gonna be on that list
imagine the girl he's gonna be flirting
when he goes to the nightclub they're
gonna say oh this is the kid that missed
the tackle ah ha ha ha imagine the kids
in high school that don't like him
because he made in the NFL and they
didn't you think they're happy he missed
the tackle absolutely they are how about
his ex-girlfriend she's definitely happy
right some of his cousins relatives are
kind of secretly happy competitors very
happy kids he played with in college
that they didn't make in the NFL they're
probably happy this guy missed it every
single night he has to watch the news
and hear his name every single game next
year when they do a national Saints game
they're gonna say this is Marcus
Williams do you remember who's Marcus
Williams he's the guy that missed the
tackle every single game until the next
time this guy wants a Super Bowl and if
he doesn't win the Super Bowl
everyone's gonna tell him everybody
remembers this play that he made in 2000
and you know 18 against the Vikings that
had cost them the Super Bowl for the
rest of his life yes to hear that now
here's what's gonna happen with Marcus
Williams if there's a person in the NFL
that's gonna grow the most between now
in the next season it's Marcus Williams
let me explain to you what
one's got more pain more humiliation
more embarrassment no one then this kid
named Marcus Williams and what's amazing
is in life you got three different types
of people fans critics and those who
play in the arena for me I was a massive
fan from 1991 to 1998 if you asked me
questions about the Lakers stats I got
them all I know the players Tony Smith
number 34 Elvin Campbell
Nick Van Exel say they'll treat Cedric
Ceballos when he scored 50 points in a
game and he had a song called flow on
flow on terrible song but we were like
this guy's the next to pop cause we were
like diehard Laker fans I could say
stats about the Texas Rangers Juan
Gonzales rusty Grier Palmeiro you will
Clark I think they had at one point as a
first baseman Juan had a swing I was you
know kind of trying to emulate his game
620 half 217 pounds home run derby
two-time MVP 96 98 I think he almost won
season he was on track to beating the
hack Wilson's RBI record I knew every
stat about people that didn't matter
Felix for me in John Cangelosi no one
probably remembers a second baseman from
Seattle Felix for me nor John Cangelosi
but I did because I was a fan and I was
a critic and no one who I was and a one
day I wake up and I say Pat how long are
you just gonna be a fan and a critic for
the rest of your life I don't want to be
that person think about it if I ask you
right now who is the greatest president
of all time you probably have an answer
you may say you know Lincoln you may say
Kennedy you may say Reagan but you have
an answer if I would ask you is the
greatest basketball player of all time
you probably have an answer if I ask you
is the greatest entrepreneur of all time
you probably have an answer but if I ask
you right now who's the greatest NFL fan
of all time you don't have an answer if
I ask you who's the greatest greatest
political critic of all time you
probably don't have an answer but
everyone knows the great once you know
why because they played in the arena
because they were willing to be
humiliated on the biggest platform they
were not embarrassed so you might go for
you is Tippy's having a couple
experiences this year that's so
humiliating that's so embarrassing
that's such a massive failure that keeps
you up at night to improve 2 3 4 o'clock
in the morning because all you're
visualizing is this will never happen to
me again this will never happen to me
again
this will never happen to me again some
of the best UFC MMA fighters became
fighters because somebody publicly
knocked them on and they say this'll
never happened to me yet this will never
happen to me again this will never
happen to me again and now you and I
know about them so don't be afraid get
in the arena and stop just being a fan
and a critic